FEMALE SPEAKER: I'd like
to introduce Mikaila Ulmer.
She is our 10-year-old
entrepreneur.
And Mikaila is going to start
off today with a presentation.
And then she'll show us a couple
of videos that she's done.
And then we'll go
into a Q&A. And I just
want to start by
saying that I think
Mikaila's a fantastic
example that you're never
too young, like Mikaila,
or too old to come up
with a great idea
and take a risk
and be daring and do something
that you've always dreamed to.
So with that, I'll let
Mikaila take it away.
MIKAILA ULMER: Thank you.
So again, my name
is Mikaila Ulmer.
And thank you for inviting me.
And thank you for coming.
Again, I'm 10 years old,
and I'm in the fifth grade.
I'm from Austin, Texas and
I am the founder and CEO
of Bee Sweet Lemonade.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I'm also a bee
ambassador, student
and social entrepreneur.
So today, I'm going to tell you
a little bit about my business
and some really interesting
facts about the bees.
And then I'm going to
show you some lessons
that I've learned on
being an entrepreneur.
But first, let's start
with a couple of bee jokes.
What did the bee
say to the sushi?
Or what did the
sushi say to the bee?
Take three guesses.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yes!
You got it right.
[LAUGHTER]
Where do bees shop?
AUDIENCE: Where do bees shop--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
Where?
MIKAILA ULMER: Bee [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
So Bee Sweet Lemonade is
lemonade sweetened with honey.
And it has flax seed.
And it's currently
bottled in glass.
We currently have four
flavors, mint, prickly pear,
half and half tea
lemonade and ginger.
Right now, something
really big is
that Whole Foods
carries our product
throughout the southwest
region of the United States.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
And we went from selling it
out of our lemonade stand
in a very small business
to actually selling it
through Whole Foods throughout
the southwest region.
And I started Bee Sweet
Lemonade when I signed up
in two kids entrepreneurial
events, Acton Children's
Business Fair and
Austin Lemonade Day.
And so I signed up in those two
events, and I needed a product.
So while I was trying to
come up with a product,
two things happened.
I got stung by two
bees in one week,
and my great granny,
Helen, sent me
a 1940 cookbook with her
favorite recipe of flax seed
lemonade.
I was very, very
scared of the bees.
And I would overreact and freak
out when they came anywhere
near me.
So my parents wanted me to just
do some research on the bees
to see if would be a little
bit less scared of them
And I did that research
and I found out
how incredibly important
pollinators they are
and how they're dying.
So I decided to create a product
that helped save the bees,
and used my great granny
Helen's recipe as well.
And that's how Bee
Sweet was born.
Now, I save the bees because
bees pollinate a third out
of all the food we eat.
And they also contribute
over $14 billion
to the US agricultural
economy a year.
So that's a lot of
money, if you realize
how special the bees are.
And I also try to save
them because they're
dying of chemical pesticides.
And here's some ways that
we can help save them.
So you can support
your local beekeepers
by buying local honey.
Or you could visit
local beehives
and learn a little bit
more about the bees.
You can plant flowers in
different colors, shapes
or sizes to give the
bees something to eat.
You can avoid using pesticides.
And chemical pesticides
harm the bees,
so you can use natural
and organic pesticides.
Or even ladybugs and praying
mantises will keep pests away.
So try to avoid pesticides
because they harm the bees.
And then share the buzz.
If you find anything
about the bees,
you can share it
with your friends
and tell your friends to
share it with their friends.
And so we can
spread the awareness
that the bees are dying
and make more of an impact
on saving the bees.
So I've been an
entrepreneur for five years.
And so--
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Here are some lessons that
I've learned while being
an entrepreneur for five years.
And so the first lesson
is, working hard is a must.
In order to start
and grow my business,
I had to work very hard.
In other words, as
people like to say,
I had to wear a lot of hats.
I had to wear a marketing
hat, finance hat.
I did workshops, teaching
families on the bees.
And I still had to be a student.
So yes, in order to
even start a business,
you have to work hard.
Lesson two is, you need
passion and a lot of it.
As I mentioned
earlier, one thing
that helped me start Bee
Sweet Lemonade was that I got
stung by two bees in one week.
And again, I was very
afraid of the bees,
and so my parents wanted
me to do some research.
And doing that
research, again, I
found out how incredibly
important pollinators they are.
And I developed a passion
for saving the bees,
learning about the bees, and
just the bees in general.
And so with that
passion, I think
that passion helped
me create my business,
a growing, successful
and thriving business.
And here's a little [INAUDIBLE]
that I made up on passion.
You need passion and a lot of
it, because the more passionate
you are about what you
do, the more fun you
have while doing it.
And so, with that quote,
that reminds me how important
passion is to my business.
Lesson three is inspiration
comes from many places.
As I mentioned earlier,
another thing that helped
start Bee Sweet Lemonade was
that my great granny Helen sent
me a 1940s cookbook with her
favorite recipe of flax seed
lemonade.
And we didn't know that
that-- well, of course,
we thought it was
special, but we
didn't know that that cookbook
would help start a business.
We didn't know it would be
an inspiration or anything,
but actually, that cookbook
was the inspiration
behind the product I chose.
And we became inspired by,
one, just how the flax seed
lemonade was made, and it
was such a special way,
and two, how they had and
utilized flax seed back
in those days, and three,
just the recipe, how
it was old and special and
passed on from our family.
So I just think that
inspiration helped
create my business, a growing,
successful and thriving
business.
And the last
lesson, lesson four,
is you can be sweet and
still be profitable.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I'm a social entrepreneur.
My business is focused
on giving back.
And I donate my time and
money to saving the bees.
And Bee Sweet
Lemonade is very proud
to say that we are making a
measurable impact on saving
the bees, and we're
profitable at the same time.
So with that, I want
everybody to conclude
that we don't have to choose
between being sweet and being
profitable.
AUDIENCE: Right.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKAILA ULMER: Again,
thank you for coming,
and thank you for inviting me.
If you'd like to learn more
about my business or my mission
to save the bees, you
can visit my website
at beesweetlemonade.com or my
social media sites, Google+,
YouTube.
So that, and I think we're
going to do videos now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]